and this is me my name is David I work
for Microsoft I am a Technical
Evangelist I live in the United States
in the great city of Chicago and I am
going to talk first of all about single
page applications single page
applications are big thing these days
there are departure from the way the the
web works years ago here's the
traditional way that the web work you
went to a browser in the old days like
five years ago okay what you do is you
would type in a URL or you would click a
hyperlink or something like that and a
request would get sent to the server and
the server would grab an HTML file off a
page or maybe you would run some code
and it would generate an HTML page and
would send that HTML along with any CSS
or images or things like that
it was send that back down to the client
to the web browser and the web browser
would grab the HTML and they would
display it it would render it it would
reload the entire page and that works ok
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that but sometimes you don't really need
to reload the whole page it's kind of a
jarring experience to repaint the entire
browser and maybe even move the user
away if they're working down you know
they've hit page down a couple times
that bump them to the top of the page
sometimes all you want to do is it
update a little bit of text on the page
and maybe store something in a shopping
cart or something like that something
that doesn't really require downloading
an entire HTML page which is a lot
dragged across the internet and then
rendering it which is kind of jarring to
the user and this work really well back
in the days when the the internet was a
way of linking together documents and
pictures of cats which is what the
original intent of the internet was
nowadays single page applications have
become really popular and with a single
page application the model is that yes
we do initially download an entire HTML
page and some JavaScript and pictures
and show it to the user
but after that if they'll click a button
or a link or something like that a
request gets sent to the server instead
of the server sitting down an entire
page it just sends down some data it'll
do some processing on the site and the
on the back end maybe you validate
something or store something on a
database
did we do a calculation but all that
gets done is sent down to the client is
enough data for the client to update the
user interface and some JavaScript in
the client will display that data to the
user may be updated div or something
like that and we do this through
javascript javascript is is a decent
language for doing this but it's that
was not a great language it's a very
small language it was written and I
think about a couple of days it's not an
extremely powerful language so we
started to build complex things like if
you saw an online email client you know
we think about how complex Gmail is
gmail.com is or or the azure portal is
there's a lot going on there it's a
whole it's really difficult as a
developer to manage that complexity
inside of a language like JavaScript so
what people did to make up for the
deficiencies of Java server the
limitations of JavaScript is that they
build frameworks to make that easier to
manage that complexity and then it's up
to you to learn those frameworks and if
the learning curve of the framework
would be offset by this idea that we can
manage the complexity of an apple single
page application manage all kinds of
state and doing data binding things like
that lots of them come up there comes so
popular that every month new frameworks
are being released to manage single page
applications and one of those was
angular angular is a really popular
framework it is open source you could
look at the source code you can
contribute to the source code you can
open bugs and fix bugs it is and it
takes care of things like data binding
and splitting up on a complex
application to smaller components and it
is managed by a company called Google
which is significant in that Google is a
big company and they've put their name
behind it and they put some of their
resources behind it and so people one of
the reasons people gravitated toward
angular is because they knew that Google
was gonna be around for a while so
having a big company behind this means
that you know if it's Joe's framework
Joe might get tired of maintaining it
and then where are we who's gonna finish
this application well Google's probably
gonna be around for a few years but
they're not just Google I mean the
anybody this room is allowed to
contribute to this application angular
has a dependency on another open-source
framework called
typescript and typescript is an
open-source framework sorry the
paparazzi's here ok I'm back
is it open suffering that is managed by
Microsoft which is kind of funny that
the Google's angular and Microsoft's
typescript are working together you know
because their competitors I work for
Microsoft and where we have this we have
competition but we also have cooperation
we have coopertition
you know office so even though we're
battling in some areas we're working
together other areas like this which is
good for you the developers that it's
actually a better experience for that
it's kind of like at all if you followed
the United States presidential election
where there were people the two
candidates clashed but afterwards they
just totally hugged about and now
they're close friends not really
but this case it's so typescript is a
superset of JavaScript means it means
that you can type JavaScript and it'll
compile it'll it'll be valid typescript
but as some other things to it as well
and when you add those other things to
it so I'm gonna talk about second what
those other things are but it makes it
easier to do development do JavaScript
development it handles some of the
limitations of JavaScript and then when
you're done it trans files down to
JavaScript and let me tell you what that
means really I so I'll start with
typescript so the idea behind
transpiling if you're a software
developer you probably know about
compiling the word compile it means to
take a text-based language like C sharp
and turn it into binary languages ones
and zeroes that's what compiling is
transpiling is like that except that
will take one text-based language in
this case typescript and will turn it
into a another text-based language
JavaScript and that's significant
because browsers don't understand
typescript they have no idea what
typescript is they can only run
JavaScript so this step is important
type scripts easier to write it's easier
to read it's easier to maintain but it
doesn't do you any good with the browser
you have to turn to them something the
browser
stance and that's what javascript is
that was a translation does so
typescript files by default will have a
TS extension and javascript files that
are generated from default will have a
Jas extension and there's one other file
actually generated by default when you
transpile and that's called a map file
as a dot map extension and the reason
this is important is that there are
tools inside of every major browser
usually you hit f12 to do it and they
let you step through the code and debug
the code they were they're really
popular they started with Firefox's
Firebug but now they're built into just
about every browser and what the map
file does is it allows you to step
through the JavaScript code but it'll
actually display the line of typescript
code that generated that JavaScript code
so then you can actually read the code
that you wrote and as it's executing
which is really a nice experience and
just to give you a picture of that
here's some JavaScript some typescript
it looks kind of nice and what a
transpose it turns into javascript the
java scripts a little bit ugly you'll
notice and the reason is because we're
going through some hoops to try and make
this do things that originally tell
javascript wasn't really designed to do
it Oh what I'm going to do is on my show
about 30 minutes of slides and about 30
minutes of sample so we'll see some
examples of that they run to do this
transposition there's a command line TSC
so you will install typescript and it's
a really quick it's like one minute
install and then TSC will by default
it'll just transpile all the TS files in
the current directory
Nats of switches you can say - p - point
it to a specific file or specific folder
you say - WTS C - W which is nice
because what that'll do is actually TSE
will stay in memory and it will
transpire changes any type script file
as it changes so every time you make a
change to a TS file it'll automatically
generate a j s file which is really nice
you can do that way there are
configuration files you can create so
you don't have to type that every time
if you want to have settings always
happen with typescript you could do that
you can set up one of your automated
deployment processes a grunt gulp and
web pack of really popular ones in the
JavaScript world to automatically run TS
c as part of the deployment with certain
set because of Visual Studio or visual
studio team systems to do your automated
deployment it's all part of your part of
the deployment process right here and
typescript pesum advantages it does let
you split things up into smaller
components but really the the biggest
advantage there's two really big
advantages one is that there's a board
Lee this creating what's called the Xmas
scripts Tanner so the JavaScript
language is really the Xmas script
language it's the official name of a
JavaScript is the implementation of the
ECMO script language specification and
some of those specifications have been
proposed but they haven't been
implemented in browsers yet so if you
want to start using some of those
features that are in the next version of
JavaScript typescript lets you do that
and then it'll transpile it into some
JavaScript that will make that happen
it'll also support types to supports
strong data typing and strong data
probably means that when I declare a
variable I specify at the time I did
clear what kind of data I'm allowed to
store in that variable and this is
something that JavaScript really hasn't
had JavaScript has always been this
thing where you could declare a variable
you could assign a string to it later on
assign a number to it later on assign an
object to a JavaScript doesn't care on
the one hand that makes it a very
flexible language but on the other hand
it's easy to let subtle bugs creep into
your code that are hard to track down
because of this and here's a simple
example of that if I have these lines of
JavaScript everywhere I've got two
variables num1 and num2 you can tell by
the names they're probably supposed to
be numbers and I assign 5 and 10 to them
respectively and then say hundreds of
lines later or maybe inside of another
function or another file I assign I
change the value of num to and I changed
not only its value but I change its data
type so now it's not someone storing a
number it's actually storing a string
now that's JavaScript fine with that and
imagine that hundreds of lines later I
go I want output the value of that maybe
I want to do assign the num1 plus num2
to the variable song and who knows what
the value of some will be in this
example what it'll be five
five ten right five one zero it'll be a
strict it wanted to be a number and that
might not be what we expect so bugs like
this they're hard to track down if you
didn't realize that you would
accidentally stored a string in here
that that could be a problem is hard to
check down with Java or with typescript
what you can do is you can declare when
you declare a variable you can declare
it as a particular datatype
so I can say num2 is a number only a
sudden numbers are allowed to be
assigned to it and then later on if I
try to assign something that isn't a
number to it it'll get an error in my ID
I'll get a little weird red squiggly
line the translation will will not
happen I'll get some message that'll
come out that are either in the console
or in the log that will tell me early on
this is a problem and as you know from
software developer you can see that
there's a problem the easier it is to
fix that problem okay here's the config
file that I mentioned earlier you can
use command line searches or you put
things into this ts config dot JSON
these are basically typing the same
thing same command lines over and over
again you can do things like specify
what version of JavaScript do I want to
generate I can specify whether or not to
generate a map file I can specify
whether to remove comments for my
texture maybe I want to keep comments in
for myself but I don't want those
comments to be in the JavaScript because
there may be they contain some secret
some secrets that I don't want the end
user to see I can specify whether I want
to allow a data type of any-any is
essentially it's like a variable key
where you can say that this one I'm not
really being quite so strict about this
particular variable I can allow or
disallow that in my configuration and I
can also exclude things from what I want
to transpile whole folders this is
useful if I want for example bring in an
external library maybe it doesn't have
any type script files that or maybe it
has type share files and they've already
been transpiled I can ignore that and
things will go a lot faster by adding
this excluder right but that's
typescript in a nutshell are there any
questions about that alright let's jump
into angular most of this talk is about
angular
and these are the things I'm going to
talk about but in here I'm just to talk
about modules modules are just a way of
splitting up your project your
JavaScript project into smaller pieces
because if you've done anything with
either set theory or with programming
you know that it's a lot easier to
manage lots of small pieces than one
gigantic piece especially those small
pieces have clearly defined interfaces
where they interact with one another
that big ball of money that one gigantic
JavaScript file with ten thousand lines
of code that's really hard to match
whereas a thousand components with
hundred lines edit is uh is a lot easier
to manage um so we can create components
we can make them use one component
inside of another which is helpful for
just managing complexity or maybe for
making creating reusable components and
here's the syntax for doing it in this
case I have a class a with a component
class in it
I'll talk about the components in a
second it has the keyword export export
means that this particular component can
be used inside of another module and in
fact this particular module I am using
something from the angular 2 core
library I am importing that so the
angular 2 core library actually has a
something called component and I'm using
that in here and through the import
keyword this is how we make our our
modules and components available and
then consume them in other ones our
components are actually the classes
themselves and they're the class
themselves that are decorated with the
add component attribute and they contain
once it has this active on Metro because
we've set some things on it we can set
templates we can set selectors here's a
little picture of it I'll show you an
example of it here templates and
selectors are really a key part of
angular so in this case I have a class
I've called a demo component and it is a
component because I decorate it with
this @ component keyword up at the top
here and at that point clear is
available to me because I have imported
component from angular 2 slash core and
the add component attribute has a couple
of properties to it it has a selector
property and a 10
what property and the selector property
allows me to create my own HTML tags and
then replace them with something on my
own some some other HTML and some codes
properties that I can use in this simple
example here my selector is my dash
selector so if I have some HTML with my
dash selector that's not a real HTML tag
it's not a valid tag but it but I if if
my application knows about angular and
knows about this component it can find
it and what will happen is it will
replace it with this template with a
corresponding template so what angular
would do what it finds this tag and
lookup it'll find the corresponding
selector and it'll replace that with in
this case h1 hello world / h1 so the
output will be first you'll see the word
loading here for a very brief time and
then when angular kicks in
it'll be replaced with that template
hello world in the larger five that's an
h1 tag so a quick word about my slides
is I've tried to make all of the
JavaScript and typescript is pink and
all of the HTML is yellow and the output
is white so you see that over and over
again so hopefully that'll sneak in and
make it easier to follow um so here the
template here is just in this case it's
one line of code actually I'm gonna
correct that really quick I just changed
my fonts right before I came in and I
shouldn't have word rapid not here so if
you'll bear with me just for a second I
will change that so it doesn't wrap is
the point I want to make in the next
slide is that in this case my template
is only one line and it's surrounded by
a single quote but if I wanted that
template to span multiple lines I would
have to use this back tic instead of my
single core the back tech just allows me
to add carriage returns to it so if I
have a longer line longer template it
probably makes sense to split it up onto
multiple lines and then little back to
that's the key that you never press on
your keyboard it's like a single quote
tilted a little bit and that's required
for multi-line templates if you want
even longer still so in this case here
I've got actually an extra line a div
that says welcome below hello
but I wanted even longer still maybe
it's gonna be a hundred lines I probably
wouldn't put it inside of this template
I would probably put it into a separate
file and in that case instead of using
the template property I would use the
template URL property here so the
template URL I would set it not to HTML
but to the name of an HTML page and that
would point to a page with all of my
HTML in it um I can also in this case I
have static HTML but I can also create
dynamic things by putting some
properties in here I'm going to cover
this later on but in this case I have
actually a class our property name
customer name it is a type string and I
set it equal to the value of David and
so that we talk about databinding this
will make more sense but right below
that you'll see that I have the word
customer name in some curly braces
around by a couple of curly braces and
that says replace that with actual name
so the output is welcome David or
whatever the value of that variable
happens to be let's talk about data
binding there's a few different ways you
could do data binding there's a one-way
data binding when my databank says that
I've got some model some in-memory data
and whatever that model changes I want
those changes to be reflected in my user
interface reflected in my user interface
on people to see whenever the customer
first name property changes I want them
to see that on screen and there a couple
ways to do that the two-way data binding
says that will happen when the data
changes then my my view will change but
also when my view changes I want my data
in memory to change as well
so if the user for example types in to a
text box or selects an item in a list
box that'll change the view and if
that's bound to some data that I want
the data on the backend to change as
well and I want anything that's bound to
that to change and then we have the
event binding event binding just says
that we're going to have some code run
in response to somebody that like the
user clicks on something or hovers over
something we'll talk about each one of
these because in JavaScript Eakes a lot
it takes quite a bit of JavaScript code
to actually change things especially a
lot of the elements on our page
I can happen automatically in angular so
interpolation is one way of doing
one-way data-binding and to do
interpolation you can just simply place
curly braces around the name of the
property that you want to display on
screen or bind to something
and what I mean by that is your here's
an example here in this case I have a
couple of properties I have I have three
properties on this class ID customer
first name and customer last name notice
I actually didn't have to declare what
datatype they are because I've
initialized them typescript is smart
enough to say oh that's a number oh
that's a string just by the fact that
I'm to I am assigning a number or a
string to it but in this example here I
have a property called customer first
name with a value of David right here
and what I can do is I can add to my
template customer first name and
surround it with these double curly
braces the double curly braces say this
is one-way data-binding
so it runtime change this whatever the
value of customer first name is place
that in place of where the double curly
brace customer first name double curly
braces and if anytime at any time that
the value of customer first name changes
like say you went from JavaScript or
somebody updates something else in the
page automatically reflect that in this
h1 tag better show you my animation
search there's the one-way data-binding
and there's the output in this case
hello data that's the value of the
customer first name it doesn't have to
be a string or a number it can be
something more complex than that in this
example I have a class so rather than
just have a customer first name a
customer last name I actually have a
customer class and it has a property a
first name and last name so in my demo
component I have a property called
customer which is of type customer and
that type customer has a first name in
last day property so now I can bind in
this case let's see there's my class
there is customer dot first name is
actually the value of that and that's
what I bind to so it could be get
relatively complex than what we're doing
this will happen automatically you don't
have to write any code to do this
and so let's see how but some examples
here in this example here I've just got
more things they're just outputting now
the customer first name and customer
last name in a couple of divs if I
wanted to do I'll come back to this so
the other way there's another way of
doing a one-way databank and though in
the interpolation model what I do is I'm
going to put curly braces around the
name of the property in the class the
other way is I could put square brackets
around the attribute that I want to bind
to so it's coming at it from a different
angle so in this case for example a
button has a disabled property and if I
want to change the value of that
disabled attribute based on something in
my model then I can bind disabled to the
name of that property in my model so in
this example here button disabled is
bound to data not changed that property
right here you notice the data not
changed when I load this is set to true
so therefore in my picture you'll see
that the button is in fact disabled
disabled equals true and if somehow I
changed they did not change from true to
false then automatically that disabled
property changes it is bound to that
property that's our one-way data mind
that always is running from the model to
the view changes the model are reflected
in the view change the view will not be
reflected in the model in this case if I
want that to happen if I want changes in
the view to be reflected back the model
I needed to do two way data binding and
the way that we need to a data binding
in an angular it's similar to the way to
the bracket way of doing one way to
dividing except for instead of
surrounding that attribute with brackets
will surround it with both parentheses
and the bracket and here's an example of
it right here so in this case I have my
same demo component it has an ID first
name and a last name property I'm sorry
has an idea of customer property which
has a first name in the last name in
this case I've actually got something an
input text box and input tucks box the
user can change the value they can type
into this text box and there's a special
angular keyword call
ngmodel an NG model we'll assign the
value of whatever is appropriate for
that control in this case it'll be the
valued property of the input and so what
I've done I'm gonna bind ng model to the
customer first name property and to the
customer class name property for these
two text boxes the one above it is just
one way data binding so what'll happen
is that because I've bound two different
things
to customer got first name then if the
user starts typing into that first name
textbox then it'll change the model
anything bound to that model will change
as well so as I change type in the text
box it automatically gets reflected to
anything else that's bound to it and
again this is done without writing any
code in your part just by wiring these
things up now to use the ng model you do
have to go into a component and import
this for modular forms module is part of
the angular core library it's an easy
thing to forget there's a little bit of
magic inside of angular we have to just
know oh it's not enough to do the data
binding I have to go over this other
file and change things and this is one
of them we need to import modules before
we could actually use them the ng model
is part of that model module there in
angular 1 there used to be a lot of
things like that to remember there are a
lot fewer of them now in the current
version of angular right and then
finally event binding event funny if you
done any programming at all any web or
Windows or any mobile programming you
know about that when the event fires you
want some code to run you bind it up a
common example is if I want to click
something about control that I put the
name of the event in parentheses in
angular and set that equal to the name
of a function to run and any parameters
I want to pass to that so for example if
I want something to happen when user
clicked on a div I would say add the
click keyword with parentheses around
that and the set is equal to the
function that I want to run for that div
here's a simple example in this case I
have a the same demo component with an
ID and a customer in it and when the
user clicks on this h1 tag at the top
right right there
then I want something to happen on click
I'm gonna run the
on click function you can see down below
there I've written an on click function
and it accepts a parameter of customer
and there was a parameter named customer
of type customer and it'll just throw up
a message box that says you clicked
customer doc first name alright that's
the basics of data binding the questions
are then this is a big deal inside of
angular data binding could require a lot
of code per tick leave you have a lot of
components on there and it could save
you a lot of complexity in your
application just by using a framework
like angular and I can start up angular
you do that the bootstrap it first thing
is there's some angular libraries you
can just set script source equals to
those and then you need a bit of code
here in your main page every pain every
application has a start page like an
index.html or main dot HTML you'll need
to import some JavaScript and that
JavaScript should have this line right
here platform browser dynamic that
bootstrap module and then the name of
your app module the name of the first
module to load and that'll point to that
and that'll be the module little load
that'll make everything else available
and also example that barista we're
almost half with you or not what time is
it make sure I'm on track
what's it half an hour ok fix all right
so I want to talk about directives here
electors allow you to attach programming
like behavior to your HTML elements and
there used to be dozens of them in
angular 1 a lot of them were eliminated
angular 2 because HTML 5 actually
created some things that allowed you to
do that so anywhere that there is a HTML
5 directive of a lord html5 were
actually available that was angular
cited just to replace it use the native
example there's still a few things left
I think the most important ones are ng 4
and ng F ng 4 allows you to allowed to
add looping functionality or application
ng if allows you to add conditional
logic to your application um there are
other ones as well and you can write
your own custom ones I'm not going to
cover that today but here's here's ng 4
in a nutshell if I wanted to loop
through say I'd array
of objects in this case they have
customer objects I've got an array of
four objects that has Satya bill Steve
and me because it's my presentation and
I wanted to bind that I wanted I
wouldn't display those on screen and I
don't know it ahead of time how many
there could be there might be four there
might be one there might be a thousand I
just want to have a separate line for
each one then I'd probably want to
create a template and loop through those
display them and that's what I'm doing
here this adding star ng 4 equals pound
cust of customers says let's loop
through this customers array and display
whatever's inside here for every single
one and bind it to this customer so cust
that last name comma cus that first name
says I'm gonna create a div it'll output
last name comma first name for every one
of those if there's four in the array I
left four lines if there's a hundred in
the rail have a hundred lines it allows
me to add that functionality so and a
lot of times this data is coming from a
web service so you don't know ahead of
time how much you're going to get in G
if let's you allow add conditional logic
to your HTML attributes and what did
what it does is it actually will
conditionally include or exclude it'll
display or hide elements inside of your
HTML and actually do more than that
it'll actually not just hide them it'll
actually remove them from the Dom which
could be significant sometimes and what
it does is ng if you'll set that equal
to some boolean expression and that
expression will return something that's
either truth e or false e truth e or
false your funny words that our
JavaScript uses false e means that it's
either false or it's 0 or it's null or
it's not a number or its undefined I
think those are those are all false e
everything else is truth e I hope I'm
not missing anything that's the idea
behind it is it's not just not just
true/false but things that are no for
example would be falsely and everything
else is is truth E and so if we set an
attribute equal to something that's
false e that everything inside of that
attribute would disappear it would be
gone it wouldn't be displayed it
wouldn't be part of the Dom which
sometimes can be useful if there's
things that would cause an error if they
were false
so here's an example of it here here
I've got a div where I've set in G if
equals true either way the star means
include the div itself in the condition
so make that appear and disappear
without the star would just take the
elements inside of it so then I'll set
if I said in DF equals true then it'll
it'll actually display but people I hate
is David inside of here if I said that
equal to false that it won't display now
you do that dynamically so in this
example here what I've got is a class
with a variable called show when the
user clicks on a button on a button that
says toggle then it'll toggle the
variable sets show will become if it's
true it'll become false if it's false
let me come true it'll make this can you
see me appear and disappear depending on
whether you've actually clicked on that
talked a little bit about lifecycle
hooks on a knit on changes on destroy
those are built into angular and they
allow you to do to run code when a
component initializes changes or is
destroyed if it's does exactly what you
say what you think it's going to do it's
really useful especially on a knit if
you are doing dependency injection which
is supported in services so the way you
do implement these things is still on
your class you would add implements on a
knit or implements on destroy and if you
add implements on an it you must add
this function ng on a knit to your class
and this becomes important when we do
services services are components that
are they're modules rather that that
don't do any user interface they just
performs some kind of logic they do some
calculation maybe they call out to a web
service and retrieve data or send data
and so they could be reusable components
or they could just be for separating out
some logic and they support inherently
they support dependency injection which
makes them easier to test the way we do
this is just by decorating a class with
the at injectable attribute and with in
adding some functions to it so this
example here I've got a class called
cusp service and has one function called
get customers that just in this case
I've just returned an array of customers
that have hard-coded in here and I've
decorated with the @ in
double attribute and once I've done that
then I can start calling it here and
here's the syntax we're calling it in
this case I've got to the arrow here
I've added to another component a
provider that says this component uses
the Custis service and then I can call
that in here by injecting this customer
service instance into this component and
this is where I'd do it here all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna rush to run short on
time here so I'm gonna rush there is a
little bit a routing if you didn't be
here used on either asp.net MVC or Ruby
on Rails or anything with routing engine
I see a bunch of hands going up so those
of you have done that you're familiar
with routing routing says we're going to
take a URL and we're going to map that
to something that's going to display on
the screen and then in in Ruby on Rails
and asp.net MVC that's always done on
the server side I want to for every URL
I'm going to call a function on the
server and it's going to generate some
HTML and send it down to the client with
angular the routing is done on the
client side which means that we don't
have to reload the whole page what will
happen is that if we have a route say
the the route route so URL whatever our
route name is we could set that equal to
some component and only update a part of
the page so this case the dark-blue is
our component and we've mapped the home
component to the root page in this URL
and if the user navigates to either by
typing a URL or clicking a hyperlinks
that they navigate to slash about that
would load the about component in that
same dark blue component but it wouldn't
reload the entire page everything around
that would stay the same same thing if
they were to slash products we could
route we could map the products
component to this and the syntax for
doing that is we create an array of
routes in our application and we set up
these these route has a path and it has
a component say whenever somebody says
/foo one load the Foo component when
everybody says slash bar we're gonna
load the bar component and we can
actually create hyperlinks there's a
syntax for doing that saying router link
Inc will slash the router link equal
slash bar it'll take care of manage
these
with relative pass and so on and there's
a special control in angular called the
router outlet control and that's the
placeholder that says this is where I
want my components to be created in the
router outlet component so for example
if the user were to click on this slash
view phoo hyperlink it would look up in
the routes tank and Euler would look in
the routes table and find which route
has a path of foo and what's the
component associated with that in this
case it's the foo component and they
would load the Foo component right here
in the router outlet that's this is the
way that it works and now I suppose they
call out HTTP because it's a common
thing that you do in a single page
application and there is a surveyor
inside of HTTP that makes it simple to
do that it's the HTTP provider and you
can import that from the angular core
library and it has this HTTP has
functions like get put post delete
allows you to call web services to just
do exactly they say if I wanted to post
to a web service this dot HTTP POST
and pass in the name of the URL that I
want to post to and then any parameters
to it it makes it really simple to call
these things there are a bunch of
providers that are provided with angular
but HTTP by far the most common want
something to call that one particular I
also want to call out observables
observe rules are a concept that's part
of the reactive library and angular has
a dependency on be reactive the with
asynchronous JavaScript program you can
use promises to manage callbacks to web
service but you can also use observables
so what the serval does is it'll watch
some piece of data and whatever that
data changes like for example a web
service gets called and returns some
value
it'll run some function and that's the
reason there are a couple of advantages
that observables have over promises one
is that they can they can be called they
can be cancelled after they're called so
I promise once you make a web service
call it's basically it's never it's
going to finish
you there's no way to cancel it and the
other is that it'll you can have a
observable function running more than
once
so that if you have a web service call
that returns let's say 20 rows at a time
you could have your function run each
time it returned 20 rows and the syntax
for doing that is right here this is
where we essentially what we do is we
subscribe to a function we have our code
subscribing to a function right here all
right um so I'm already about 40 minutes
into it about 20 minutes left for demos
so I'm gonna bring up some demos we go
as far as we can are there questions it
alright now okay let's jump into here
what I'm gonna do is to get started in
this and you close all this stuff right
here didn't mean to do that
come on close it close that don't lose
my facebook page guys when you look at
that all right
angular dial is where a lot of go get
started and on here guess what I'm gonna
do to get started here I'm gonna click
get started in fact I'm going to zoom in
a little bit here so you guys can see in
the back and in here there's a couple
things to you let's see so learning and
click that's learning angular this is
kind of nice
there's a set up for the angular
development and on here there are links
to install things like node which is a
nice let's see open that new tab here no
no let's just do that
no js' that's where it is no js' is a
javascript a server-side javascript
framework so it concludes actually some
a simple web server it's a wonderful
tool at it's it's cross-platform it'll
run on my PC will run on Mac and around
Linux it takes like a minute to download
and then a couple minutes to install IO
is there's two versions you either do
the the stable version or the bleeding
edge version I was do the stable version
and because it knows on my window
windows it just showed me the windows
first buddy good download of Mac version
as well also you can download typescript
as well if I go right here it is the
typescript Lang org
site and you can bring that again it's
it takes like a minute to download and I
meant to install it's very fast and then
the other thing I have to have some kind
of editor you could use notepad I guess
but I use Visual Studio code which is at
Visual Studio code code that Visual
Studio cop and this is also a really
nice cross-platform
editor that it's takes about a minute to
install and then it's downloaded the
minute to install so it's really nice
those are the tools that I'm gonna be
using here and this kind of walks you
through how to do that so I'm not going
to do that right here what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna do they get starter set
up within there and jump into this
tutorial right here so we're not we only
have about 15 minutes left so I'm not
gonna get too far in this thing but you
can go to angular 2 IO and do the same
thing yourself it'll build this tour of
Heroes thing in fact I'll show you what
the end is supposed to look here's the
if you go through the whole thing this
uses plunker which is a nice online way
to share javascript files or your files
over here and i should show it where
these are all superheroes so there's
magenta she's a superhero and there's
you could change magentas name to
magenta and show a list of all the
heroes here select one i can add a new
one David and there we go right there
and now David Mann's down here and
dashboard I guess is the most popular
heroes are right here so on I get search
for David is he yeah let's grab him
stuff like that and change things like
that
alright so that's what we're working
towards here so let me go back to here
right there and actually build some of
this stuff so if I go down to here I'm
gonna build an editor and what I want to
do is to get started the way I like to
get started is there is a setup
instructions for there's just like a
some bootstrapping code that I can just
grab right here right here where did it
go there was a link to a quick start
download the quick start to see there it
is and I don't see it why not
I don't get up thank you and I get us go
download this right here you can clone
it but I just like to download it so
download the zip file and zip it and
this does the the bootstrapping for me
it creates an HTML page start page for
me and does a couple of files for me
it's open that up and I will extract it
to I've got a folder called test angular
right here and let me rename that to a
and G oh five to six right here so I
just unzipped the whole thing to right
here and from this I know if you know
this in Explorer you can just type CMD
it'll open up a command prompt right
here and I'm gonna just type NPM node
package manager install because I've
already installed node and the package
manager is just a nice way of installing
a bunch of stuff and what that's gonna
do I did that first because I wanted to
it's gonna take about two minutes to do
that let me open up my command window
I'll type code dot that'll launch Visual
Studio code in this directory right here
and you'll notice that there's uh just a
little bit of stuff in here there's some
source code in here if i refresh it
eventually we'll start to see some other
stuff appearing is this thing execute
you see is going along here what's going
on here when I did npm install is it's
looking at this file right here
package.json so in package.json i've got
some things that it can install down
here dependencies it's gonna look at
this file and say i need to install the
angular common library the angular
compiler the angular core library and
this is the version that i want to
install of each one of those there's
some dependencies down here like light
server which is a lightweight node based
webserver
that'll ride typescript i want to
install that here version 2.1 point o is
the version that i want all sorts of
things that is going to stall it'll also
give me some
our custom pant come some commands so I
said NPM build for example it'll run the
TSC compiler and the - P lets me point
to a particular folder in this case the
source folder right here it'll transpire
that if I say say npm start right here
it'll concurrently run npm build : watch
build : watches this it'll transpile the
source folder and the - w says stay in
memory if any TS files change
automatically transpile those and then
also run a server which is my light
server with a couple of configuration
options on there so that's what right
now we're just doing this right here
installing all this stuff here let's see
where it is it's all done and if I
reflect that you'll see that I now have
this node modules thing and it contains
all my angular core libraries right here
and some other dependencies as well all
kinds of stuff that's available to me so
I transpile this I probably don't want
to transpile all this node module stuff
and in fact I've got in my TS config
file I actually exclude those so I have
when I go into my let me go to my source
folder here and you know here's my start
page HTML I'm bringing in the angular
core libraries this is just part of that
zip file that I I unzipped it brought it
here here's my or isn't system does
import I'm importing main j/s oh they
changed it example here but system dot
import mange s main Jas is you notice we
only have main TS right here but that's
going to going to transpile into main
Jas and it's going to do here we go
platform browser dynamic that bootstrap
module app module at module is right in
here
here is app module so this is gonna be
it's gonna kick off this will be the
first component that I have in here
alright so I needed to start this thing
off and the way I got started off is
going back to the command line and
saying npm start and over npm start go
back to here and i'll show you that in
my config file packages npm start
says do I currently do a bill run bill
watch which is at ESC - P that's W and
then run the server so I'm going to do
that
that'll transpile everything so all the
TS files with will generate a map file
or generate a J s file and it'll start
my server
there's my server right there okay there
it is okay and go back to here right now
it's saying hello angular and the reason
is saying hello angular is because in my
I have a component right here notice
first of all do this I used to just have
app component es and now I have app
component that Jas was generated right
here it's a little bit uglier but does
the same thing even for the simple one
it's still generating some ugly code and
I also have an app component J s map
which is a mapping thing that I could
step through the code so app that
component you'll notice it's just got a
component here
it's decorate with the add component
attribute which it got from the angular
core library right here it has a
selector my app and has a template hello
and my might default page is this
index.htm index.html right here and you
notice it has a tag my app not a real
tag but it says loading app component
here dot dot dot we should see that
flash of that but then as soon as
angular kicks in it should be replaced
with hello and then whatever the value
of this name is is bound to that one way
which is angular so that's what we see
here I'll refresh that I see loading app
Capone here and then quickly it switches
to that and in fact if I change this I
say hello clues for example and save
file save then it's pretty nice because
I don't have to hit refresh it
automatically detects that this server
and it'll reflect the changes to that if
I spelled it right there that's hello
oh I deleted something didn't mean to do
that equals clues
cynical there we go accidentally to that
and there it is right here all right
thanks
ten points to Gryffindor all right let's
go through this thing here we don't
behind schedule schedule right here so
go back to here back to here and I'm
just gonna step through some simple data
buying stuff that's good back here we go
and build an editor so what I'll do is
I'm gonna create in my app component a
couple of properties so here's my app
components right there and I'll replace
that I replace this with a couple
properties here so so just having a name
of that title and hero that's gonna
break this I don't have a name so I want
to replace this with title and hero and
I'll change my template actually to this
right here right there and save it and
you'll see close all these things right
here
now it says tour of heroes for the title
and windstorm details because it's got
hero and details and then title this
tour of heroes right there so a nice
simple thing there I'll come back here
and I'll change it to let's not just use
instead of hero being just a string
let's make it be something more complex
we'll create a class called hero and
then we'll change this to here well if I
just do this let's see how change that
from hero equals one storm to hero of
type hero how about that that's gonna
break things I still have hero up here
but now you notice it doesn't show up
here what I really want to do is to
change my let's see let's do this copy
code let's do that so now I've actually
assigned a hero till they're still wrong
here this is this is gonna be an object
now if I go back to this you'll see it's
object object that's no good what I want
to do is to change like template right
here so instead of that being just hero
it'll have to be hero dot name would
work here save that and now I should see
windstorm dpl's right back where I
should be all right
let's make it a little bit more complex
change our template to this right here
it's multi-line so we use this back tic
symbol here now we've got the title and
the name the ID and the name different
font sizes we should see that here yeah
title the name the ID and the name
they're all about but it's all one-way
data-binding so let's change that to
using an input tag that'll show a text
box on here we want to do two-way
data-binding let's so we're gonna set ng
model equal to hero name here that's
what we'll do we'll change our template
right there
so the user can change oops change that
did that work
troll Z maybe yeah I wanna call up to
dev I think that's right
right here I want the name and then view
our place to label and there we go so
this is this whole thing here should be
placed control V that's right and it
isn't working so I'll tell you what
let's debug let's go to our f12 tools
f12 tools right here and see why it's
not working
refresh the page and something should
show up in there console which tells me
why it's not working and I get ngmodel
ah ng-model is not defined that's
because I didn't do what I told you you
have to do and what you have to do is
you have to tell it up you need to
import the forms module in order to use
ng model so I skipped this step right
here in my app dive module right here I
need to tell it that I'm going to import
this forms module and that's what's
going on right here let's grab that here
I need to import the forms module right
here and to use that I have to get that
from my angular slash forms node module
and that should work and there we are so
now I have two way data binding here so
what that means is that I change this
this right here the user interface
it automatically changes the model which
automatically changes anything bound to
that model alright about four minutes
lesson I try and do one more of these
before I let you out here so in this
case I'm going to add add a one-to-many
relationship so now I'm just displaying
one here oh let's add in our app
component will add a another class
called heroes which is type array of
hero and there's ten heroes in here mr.
nice narco etc we'll want to add another
property here of type heroes let's do
that right here we'll set heroes equals
this constant of heroes down here all
right
and then we'll want to then we want to
display all ten heroes and we maybe not
don't know ahead of time how many heroes
are a good way to display a list is with
a ul tag Li where does something like
this let's copy this code right here we
don't know exactly what it's going to
look like but we'll go into here and
we'll say in our template right below
the title we'll add this and we'll say
how are we gonna loop through this and
we all we know we have something called
ng for that lets us loop through an
array so we're gonna do that we're gonna
do this Li ng for star equals let which
just says scope it to this Li tag hero
of Heroes so let me replace this let
hero of Heroes and every time it goes
into here we'll have a variable called
hero which will be one of these or is it
the hero's property which is this array
down here and whatever I type in here
that's what's wanted to get displayed
over and over again once for each hero
so it should have ten rows of that in
fact if I do just put X's in there this
should work right here I should just do
ten X's and there they are but I want to
bind something to it so let's grab this
right here we're gonna bind just a span
with hero dot ID and hero dot name let's
do that like that
say that and now we should see there
they are it's a little bit ugly so let's
add some styling to it down here and one
way you can add styling is with a styles
attribute of the component just an array
of style sheets if I come back down here
and just below this and styles equals
you notice I have a style for Heroes Li
and has certain font size I had in my
template I had a class called badge the
special styling for badge
so let's we'll see that and now it looks
a little bit nice so it's even a hover
thing that goes on there and the only
thing I'm missing here is that you know
when you click on this it doesn't this
thing is hard-coded they're not actually
seeing that and we can do that by
binding event by binding a function to
the click event
we're just fairly easy we just put right
here something like click equals on
select hero so we can do that let's do
this right here grab that and in my
template in my li so whenever the user
clicks on one of these list items I want
this on select functions around which I
haven't written yet so I need to come
down here and write that function here
it is it just says this stops selected
hero equals zero so I pass in the
current hero on a past and whatever this
current hero is in this loop and I'll
set in my function right there this does
select the heroes I'll have select a
hero yet let me change that I have
something called hero let's change hero
to selected hero how about that and
we'll let's see then we have to I've
changed sectors that's gonna break some
things up here I need to change this
from hero to selected hero and this from
zero to select the arrow on this from
hero stuck here and I think that will
work got everything right and there it
is so now what'll happen is if I click
on doctor IQ now doctor IQ actually
becomes that and it's still all by data
binding still MERS so we are right at
I'm and what I want to encourage you do
is go to angular dial if you want to do
some more of this and just continue this
I deliberately picked a tutorial that
you can continue on your own
and I will stick around I'll be right
outside of here when the next figure
comes in so if it allows to ask me a
questions I am very much available thank
you so much for your time and for having
me
[Applause]